RETO MEIER: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a veritable
buffet of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch the session Google Cloud
Storage Best Practices,
then stay tuned,
because here is the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Google Cloud
Storage offers a great set
of features for
writing, storing,
and distributing content
for whatever application
you're building.
COLT MCANLIS: When you're
considering performance
for your GCS use
case, most people only
consider whether
they should set up
the bucket to be regional,
multiregional, nearline,
or cold storage.
RETO MEIER: But there's
a few more things
to consider, if you'd
like to really maximize
your performance.
In general, GCS is really
strong in terms of single stream
throughput.
However, there's typically a
fixed latency cost per request.
So obviously, for
the best performance,
you should really favor
larger requests in order
to optimize your throughput.
COLT MCANLIS: But this
isn't always an option.
Sometimes you're just
stuck with small objects.
In which case getting
the best performance
means paralyzing your requests.
So there's overlapped
fix latency costs
and avoiding resumable requests
since the overhead of round
trips on lots of small
objects can add up
to be a significant problem.
RETO MEIER: Now,
when serving data,
you generally have the choice
of regional or multiregional
buckets.
Regional is really good
for compute scenarios,
because you typically want your
VMs close to your data source
to maximize throughput.
And you don't want the
overhead of bookkeeping
that's needed for
multiregional redundancy.
You'll see higher
throughput in this case.
Multiregional, on
the other hand,
is great for serving
content since it can achieve
great remote latency
due to usage of CDNs
where Google will
automatically push assets
to the edges of its network
based upon usage patterns
without you having to
do any heavy lifting.
COLT MCANLIS: Now,
writing data to GCS
is a completely
different problem.
Most people when
writing to a GCS bucket
quickly find that they
hit a wall or ceiling,
basically a point when which
things don't get any faster.
When we see this,
we generally find
that the developers are
writing sequential file
names to their GCS buckets.
The reason this causes
a performance problem
has to do with how GCS
shards and load balances
your write requests
internally so that they scale.
When you've got
sequential names,
the balancer can't properly
segment and move things around
as efficiently,
hence the bottleneck.
RETO MEIER: Now, to
address this, firstly,
try to submit buckets
of work in parallel.
For example, the
foo and bar folders
can be uploaded in
parallel without stomping
all over each other.
Secondly, consider prepending
a hash of the filename
to the filename itself, which,
given the distributed nature
of your hashing
algorithm, will create
a non-linear distribution
of filenames,
resulting in better
load balancing.
If you'd like some more details
on these GCS performance
optimizations as
well as a cool demo
on using a Hadoop with GCS,
check out the full next video.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]